Okay, we are
back. Second session of
going? So
close. So close to here. All right,
we'll let that take a little bit
longer. Instability is kind of
silly. We were going to look at clipping
now,
right? So, I just tried removing
clipping from what I thought would be an
end where it wouldn't
matter, and it totally broke.
right? Let's rerun it like
this. See if it still
breaks. This should only use each sample
like one time.
problems. So,
um, Whoops.
I uh I guess I was totally wrong
there. I didn't think the clipping would
make that much of a
difference. I figured it would only make
a difference if you're running a ton of
epochs.
Oh, the kale exploded here,
right? Four, five. Yeah, the tail
exploded. Does that make any sense at
all?
Like, right, hang on. What if we try?
Let me try things
here. We return
clipping or up to eight pots.
You go slow mode.
It's possible this is not strictly
better even though it should be,
better. So, I'll go on record as I
saying that I thought that I'd looked at
the math a couple weeks ago and I
thought that I'd figured out that for
the most part the on policy off policy
distinction was a joke. Uh, it's not. As
it turns out though, the thing that is a
joke is that
um even Rainbow seems to be
kind of breaking its own math
assumptions. It's not like I is off
policy is the correct one of the two.
like this is fine,
right? If you crank up the update
box, you don't really break anything.
Yeah, it doesn't seem like you really
break
anything. Let's check the
[Music]
spike, but I mean otherwise it tracks
pretty well and that's a perfect
sol. What happens if you really crank
this up?
I'm just trying to see if clipping is
like a band-aid path or if it's
actually
stable the way we would think
I'm really surprised about the clipping
thing
Yeah, there's clearly stuff going on
here that I do not understand yet.
So, the thing that I'm not sure here,
right, is like I was kind of looking for
just chuck all the methods on stuff real
quick to see if anything happens.
Anything surprising like we did get the
big nice boost from
Muan.
Oh, I see.
Wait, the PG lost
is advantage.
props. Oh no, that is good. Yeah, that's
how clipping should work.
um, yeah, the PO clipping is not a fix
or off policy. It's a band-aid.
Like you can still go too far off in
just one
epoch. Yeah. Look at this thing. Can we
even see this in the losses anywhere or
is it just
bad? Not really. Right.
Entropy is
fine. We're not logging
that. Prox K scale is
fine. You do see the value loss quite
different
clipping is is in fact
essential. It is actually going to keep
training on this and
uh it is
improving. I mean that definitely
damaged it.
That was an unexpected result. I'm
trying to think where we go from
there. I really didn't think clipping
was going to make a huge difference in
like one update epoch training.
Hang on. What if it's an optimizer
issue? Let's Let's roll one other thing
out. Let me just rule one other thing
out here.
um like an optimizer
issue. So essentially if we still clip
but we give it like a really big bounce.
What? So this is literally like some
dumb optimizer thing, right?
like So we have This thing,
right? Where was
it? Now, where was the run that totally
exploded? Yeah, this one.
Right. We should actually see this in
the
losses. Yeah. So, this thing just blows
up instantly.
I don't know about you, but that doesn't
strike me
as flipping to keep the thing on policy
or whatever. That strikes me as like
flipping to prevent uh bad update from
destroying the policy, right?
Let's try 02 real quick because this was
the value used in the paper. Make sure
there's not something magic going on.
It's crazy that you clip the loss and
you clip the gradient.
I figured that clipping the gradient
would be enough to prevent screwy
optimizer stuff from
happening. But I guess
not cuz if you get like a bad advantage,
right? If you get a bad
advantage, you could take like a 0.5
gradient step in the completely wrong
direction. How's this
do? Yeah. So, this actually it does a
little better than 0.1 but it
underperforms
0.5. Let me see what these clip
coefficients actually do.
clipping. So it doesn't let the old log
props get too far away from the new
ones. Okay.
Then the
gradient there's also the gradient
clipping. And then the value function
clipping
is this one's weird,
right? Yeah. This one is just like
directly in
um you're literally just plus minus a
constant on the loss. That's
crazy. Oh no, it's clipping the value
loss to plus
minus this constant.
Okay. Does this thing get
normmed? This doesn't get normed at
Um, the fact that this has like such a
wide
window. Kale's kind of bad at the same
time, isn't
it? Kale's like kind of bad.
Let's go back to the old replay
one. Set this to one and see what
happens.
So this is now potentially like
massively off policy.
Bye.
Okay, let me try one thing.
So now this is not training the value
loss on stale data but still training
the policy.
better. Okay.
So, let's not do
trades. Okay. So, this this toilet paper
is also what introduces
Brays. They have an ablation within
without
thing? Yeah, there's a big difference
here. Big difference.
Uh, and you see with the replays, but
this is what gives them access to this
replay buffer. So, this is kind of
exactly what we
want. The Vray
uh targets are defined by
here. All policy learning is important
in the decoupled distributed actor
learner architecture because the lag
between actions are generated by the
actors and when the learner estimates
the gradient. Yes.
trajectory X
a reward from S. So this is perfect.
This is exactly what I have.
We define nstep v trace target for the
value
function sum over the trajectory
segment
gamma some crazy
product the
TV. Okay, this is I think the thing that
is worth investing into right now.
This is a thing that's worth investing
into.
We also should open up. Let me switch
the
view cuz we need
to This is going to get
heavy. Okay, so here's our current
target from generalized advantage
estimation.
some
gamma
delta. They have this product and then
they have delta and then they have
this Xt + 1 - XT
But this is only a one step,
right? This is literally only a one
min. This is
average.
weights. In the on policy
case when pi equals m
And then you get the on policy endstep
element which is
right
here which is lambda equal
one. So this thing
recovers that
update. I also want to use the same
algorithm for off and on policy data.
truncated important sampling weights CI
and
PT. Well, this is what is this row or
something. I actually don't
remember.
Hey, I know that pace weird.
Okay, we don't care about the tabular
case.
V trace targets can be computed
recursively.
Did this one come with source
code? Yes, this one
us
this. Jeez. Okay, this is actually it's
row. That's what it is. It was
row.
Um, they have this and they have a test
for it because this is a very important
thing to get right.
Let me just uh briefly look up if
there's been any successor to be trace.
right? Oh, yeah. This is Showman's
follow up to his own stuff.
Oh yeah, this has the weird thing where
um
Choosing the optimal level of sample
reuse is not straightforward.
value policy and value function trainer
decoupled. We can train with different
levels of sample
reuse. In order to better understand the
impact, we chose to vary the number of
policy epochs without changing the
number of value function epochs. That's
actually very similar to what I just
tried to
do. Get out of here, bot.
I build the bots around
here.
Um, single policy epoch is almost always
optimal or near optimal in
ppg. This suggests that the PO
baseline benefits from greater sample
views only because the experts offer
additional value function training.
But isn't the value function data what
gets off
policy? I mean it is also the supervised
one that you can train perfectly, right?
So that doesn't suggest that uh you can
use that you can reuse samples, right?
Oh,
okay. These are literally
inverted. Okay.
Man, I love when I just have, you know,
a whole day to just get as deep into the
literature as I need to to try to
understand stuff. This is good.
Too many
epochs runs the risk of overfitting to
recent
data. Not with a giant batch. Fewer
epochs will lead to slower training.
1 to
n training with auxiliary epox is
generally
beneficial up to
six. We may expect better train features
to be shared with the policy or train a
more accurate value function.
The feature sharing appears to play the
more critical
role. Auxiliary phase
frequency. We next we investigate
alternating between policy and auxiliary
phases at different frequencies.
We perform each auxiliary phase after
end policy
updates. Performance suffers when we
perform auxiliary phases too
frequently. As an alternative to
clipping that's
me this guy's own paper.
proposed using an adaptively weighted KL
penalty. We now investigate the use of
the K penalty in BPG. Instead, choose to
keep the relative weight of this penalty
Okay. Fixed KL performs remarkably
similarly to clipping when using PPG.
Clipping is more important when using
when rewards are poorly skilled. Great.
I don't have to do a bunch of math.
Lovely. They want to keep the tail
penalty for the theoretical insights
even though it's a pain in the ass. It's
funny.
default implementation of
PPG a single network
variant that mimics the same training
dynamics PO for
reference PPO PPG PO single they're very
similar ppg comes with an increased
memory footprint since we use disjoint
policy and value function networks
instead of a single unified network we
can use we use approximately twice as
many parameters
We can recover this f by using a single
network that appropriately detaches the
value function gradient.
phase we detach the value function
gradient at the last layer
shared uh preventing the value function
from influencing shared parameters.
In the auxiliary
phase, the value function gradient with
respect to all
parameters.
Okay. I I think they did some whatever
that's
fine. Work
conclusion. Very good.
Do they have algorithm pseudo code
somewhere? Yes, they
do. Initialize empty
buffer. Perform
rollouts. What's
var value function
target? I missed
this and var computed with generalized
advantage estimation.
right. So perform allows compute value
function
optimize the policy for some
box. Optimize the value for some
Wait. And then there's L joint and L
value. Okay. I don't think I
uh I fully understood what the heck
they're doing here then.
We optimize the policy network with a
joint
objective that includes an arbitrary
auxiliary
Lox. Hold
on. You don't need this.
Wait, let me try the
single. What's the single
one? By default, PPG comes with an
increased memory
footprint. Since we use disjoint policy
and value function networks instead of a
single unified policy, we can use
approximately twice as many parameters
compared to
PO. Recover this cost by using a single
network that appropriately detaches the
value function gradient. During the
policy phase, we detach the value
function gradient at the last layer
share between the policy and the value
heads. Preserving the value function
gradient from influencing shared
parameters.
phase, we take the value function
gradient with respect to all
parameters.
Huh. Okay. So, that's not
quite. But then what does the auxiliary
phase
do? Hang
on. So they just do Where's the pseudo
Optimize L
joint. Optimize L
value. Okay. I don't understand this
thing.
perform
rollouts under current
our thought they had ppg in here, didn't
they?
PPG pro
jump policy
phase. So they collect
rollouts, right?
Optimize policy and value
network. There's the policy network
one. Uh, and they do these at the same
time because they're separate networks.
Okay. But then there's an auxiliary
phase policy.
need to understand this and need to
understand B trace today. Those are the
two
goals. What's this B as what's this
extra thing?
That's just
entropy. So in the first
phase, this is just do PO,
right? Yeah. This is literally just do
PO with a stop Brad potentially if you
use a shared
network. Okay, so that's super
easy and this is not even slower.
This is not even slower than PO
providing you use the shared
formula. But then there's this E
O where you
optimize L
So what is
Ljint? We optimize the policy that has
an auxiliary loss and a behavioral
cloning
loss. So this is the value function
loss.
Okay. So in the shared version, the
shared policy version, this is
uh this is literally
just train the value
loss. And then this thing
old. Oh. Oh, okay. I understand this.
So, they're trying to keep this thing
outputting the exact same actions
um
while training it to match the value
see that's
clever. Let me think why that makes
sense though to do it this way.
Let me make sure I got
the this this is
V theta
V. Yeah, this is theta V.
Do you even have to do this? I wonder
with the shared formula.
Like this is arguably not even that hard
to do, right?
though. Now that I understand this, let
me go back through the experiments
again.
three? We chose to vary the number of
policy epochs without changing the
number of value function
epochs. Results are shown in figure
three.
wild. So that's literally just train the
policy
and then they get literally the opposite
with the value function, right?
Then here is the auxiliary phase
frequency.
phase. So, you don't actually have to do
this very
often. Wait, now wait, we have
additional epochs during the auxiliary
phase.
ox. Hang on. This is e
pi. E
ox. So, they didn't do
this. I thought they did do this
one. So, this one is
EI. No, this is not EB. This is Es
frequency. So, this is not that bad then
because you do have to run some extra
epoch, but you don't do it that often.
is probably pretty awful though
for M
speed. You can't really do anything on
the end while you're optimizing that.
That's okay. Okay. So, I understand this
thing. I think this is going to have no
bearing whatsoever on uh V
trace. So, this is something to
investigate for
trace. And now we try to understand this
V trade Target.
S to tus
one sum i=
s to t yeah so this is fine this is not
this is actually easy to
compute then
ci i over
mu okay and then this delta
21 billion frames per day, 250k
fps
CPUs. Oh, and then that's you actually
have to divide by four.
Yeah. So, this is actually 60K. Yeah,
that's about what you can do with a
GPU. That's
funny. That's actually pretty
disappointing
for looking at what Puffer does these
days because I can give you half of that
just like out of the box.
CPUs.
So okay in order to implement this thing
implementation. So that's the current uh
No, it's in
shared. Okay. So J is just
reward plus gamma value minus it's this
right this okay this is all that this
I'm covering the screen. Hang on. We'll
do this for
Then you can literally just do this,
right? Yeah, it's just the sum of
these. And then you don't even have the
lambda
term, right?
So really I just need this row term and
this C
term. So let me see if I can understand
these.
Row and C are truncated important
sampling
weights. Where do they
define? So MOU is the original policy.
So this is pile
B P bar as a truncation
threshold. Oh, is that a constant?
right? That might literally just be a
constant.
If that's just a constant, this isn't
that hard to implement.
though? Are these just parameters that
are going to be listed somewhere for us?
Are those not just fixed diapers? Cuz I
don't see them
anywhere. Just count.
one. Okay. So, if that's correct, those
are literally just one.
Okay. Now, let's go back one more time
and see if I understand why this is the
way it is. So, this
is there's no lambda in
here. Let's ignore lambda. So,
discounted. So, we're just doing
Bellman. Okay. No exponential smoothing
with
lambda value plus. So if we ignore this
piece here and this clipping then this
gives us Bellman which is this right
here and
Bellman. So what we're saying
here let's do this one first. This one's
easier.
advantage or rather we're scaling the
advantage based on important
sampling instead of scaling
the policy gradient loss directly.
Oh, that also scales the value function
target, doesn't it?
Important sampling is embedded in the B
trace
target. Corrected value estimate
indirectly influences advantage
computation by correcting value function
B trace advantage accounts policy
mismatch is not directly applied to the
advantage itself. What's the value
function that is
adjusted? Uh, what this is? Is this the
advantage function they
use? That seems weird. I got to check
loss. Clipped objectives with policy
loss.
typically unclipped or L2 loss value
function.
Now there is important sampling right.
The clip is on
um a logic
towards towards one step, right? If you
add Yeah, because lambda is one default.
So yeah, this just pushes you away.
Lambda just pushes you towards
this which is really easy to optimize
but this is like a onestep
bootstrap. So this is hard to optimize
but is correct, right? More
correct. This is the end step or the
infinity step. So you might not even
need a lambda term.
Okay. It is not It is not more common to
see unclipped value loss in PO. That is
not
true. The value function.
Now, let me just do what they use for
the advantage function here
because I'm a little suspicious
now. So, here's your V trace
target, which is what you train the
value function against. And where's your
advantage function?
Just make sure I understand this as
well.
here. So, this is just the value
target. Did they give us the advantage?
do. Hang on. This is the V trace target,
right?
Oh, wait. No, this is the same. Isn't
this the
same?
Because
advantage you
add BST to this, right?
You do V st plus
this which if it's equivalent
here R + lambda V S T + 1
right? No, it's not because this
[Music]
is reward
plus
advantage. Yeah. Okay, that's still
fine. That's the
same. So, this is actually a very sort
of
similar
method. What did they benchmark this
against?
correction. Is no correction generalized
advantage estimation or no?
No off policy correction. Multiply
advantages by corresponding importance
weight. That gives you very similar
performance.
Without replay, it gives you very, very
similar performance. With replay,
there's a bit more of a
gap. There's no benchmark of betray
generalized advantage estimation.
Probably worth implementing this thing
still.
This thing needs values.
Rewards
C. And this is going to be fairly
similar to
J. Let me see this double loop real
quick.
one. So this product is pretty easy to
compute, isn't
it? It's just one term
per Okay.
back? This one can't be computed
backwards,
Wait, this is a t and this is a
i. But this is
ct. So this is the same thing.
min
max
that's or actually we can do it the
other way
right so we do
prod times equals
this. You only need this component,
right?
Wait, this is rewards of T
next. Is that
This index and the negative are the
same. The
values Yeah, that looks like a bug to
me.
Okay. So cool. I think we can just start
implementing this portion
this. We'll start with this delta.
So this delta is just equal to reward at
I'm going to make this
t
next minus values. Okay, so this delta
is fine.
This is just a
backwards sum,
This is not a T. Next. This is a T,
right? This is
T. It's
terminal times a
cube and then trace of t is equal to a
cube. I think that's it except I missed
the
What's this? The road
clip. Ah, shoot. You missed the road
clip. You click twice like that.
This is not it's not uh this is
important
T. Yeah. So this is it here. So this is
the clipped row and then this is row
clip
delta. And then we can do this one in
line I think.
So this one should
This has to go
here. And then this is actually
subt. I want to keep it the math as I
possibly
is there no value function bootstrap on
this
Oh, there is
right. Yeah, there
is. So, it's going to be delta Q is zero
at the first time. So, cro delta plus
gamma times
that I think that's correct.
compile. I'm gonna actually move this.
I'm going to move
this. I move this
down. I mean, this should basically be
autocompletable. It's so basic, right?
Check on this board is done is
steps trace
row clip. Yeah, there we
go. So then we just do
Rewards values done importance and trait
should all have the same
dimensions should be two dimensions on
the same
device in 432 will
Right. Now we
do
That's the shared
shared
file. Now we need the
bindings. And this is actually, believe
it or not, this is going to be the C++
and the CUDA at the same
time. It' be very
nice. We'll do the C++ bind first.
V
trace values rewards done
importance advantages clip clip thumbs
horizon plus horizon beach
row importance plus
offset.
Okay plus offset row
clip horizon. You missed gamma
completely man. What the heck is wrong
with you?
And you use it here too, don't
you? Gamma, what's wrong with
you?
Lo, this doesn't need to get checked
though,
right? Like the uh the check on this
doesn't
include any of this
good. Okay. Now, the actual function
here needs
everything
trace
gamma. All right. And then you do B
Is this the right
one? Yeah, I think this is the right
one. So, we
believe. Okay. And then there's compute
GA.
Just do
this
trace kernel which takes values rewards
done
importance
trace gamma
row clip.
Yep. All
that and then it's just V trace with the
new RS.
And then that will give us our
kernel. We still have to bind this
thing. So let's actually put this down
here. I don't know why I did this this
way. This should
go. What is this thing? Yeah, I don't
know why I did it this way. This needs
to go down here.
there. All right. Base is kernel
now just needs a
binding which passes
in everything
except perfect.
Uh, that might have just one shot it
because this is super basic. Let's see.
BR
Yeah.
GMA looks good to
me. Just a bunch of boiler
plate. And then we just have to
export QV trays.
Okay. Well, you don't give it
experience. importance,
right? Yeah. So, this is like
um what you need to do this needs to be
important and then we have to do
We need
um old log props and new log props,
right?
Does this thing prevent you from doing a
prioritized
This says that you need to have the
importance
ratio before you compute advantage,
right? How does prioritized experience
replay work?
Maybe we can just use something else to
sample it with and then we don't need
advantages.
Uh I don't have I don't have mental
bandwidth to read another full paper
here right yet. Hang
on. Let me just uh think what we can do
in the meantime.
So, oh, I see what we would
do. So, we would just do
back. So this is now
uniform, right?
Then we
do if config use V
trace we need to
get we need to compute J for this
B. So this is going to be B
rewards from the
gamma. Okay. And then we do
importance
ratio, right?
That is the important
sample. Oh, I totally messed this up.
Hang
on. I just Yeah, I know how to do this
now.
Okay. So, we do
this manages four
once we go down to
here. We say
ratio.
Okay.
Advantage.
Or what's
this? This is not advantage. This is V
trace,
Var. And what's the V trade paper make
me use for the act
policy? What they
use? So this gives you VS.
right? Yeah. Value function
is easy. This is just batch returns,
right?
batch. So that's an easy target. Now
what do you do for the only thing I
don't know is the
Oh yeah, this log ratio is
uh yeah going to be completely
completely different,
right? So it's going to be
um PG
dot gamma batch returns minus batch
values. I think this is
it. I think that is it.
And then we have to
right. Zero chance that this runs on the
first
try. Oh, I also unless I forget to
enable it.
Ah, this is a bad
ting. There's a bug.
there. Let's see what that
builds. All right. How many bugs we
Uh, you just straight up forgot to add
this. Yeah, that was
Not bad though. That will immediately
have a CUDA kernel for
it. So if it works, it'll also
immediately be fast.
Can I just do con? Can I like
const this
I just have to get it so that the thing
will let me use this
um for a static array.
Okay. Expression must have a constant
value.
Guess I can't do
that. That's very obnoxious.
Why did I need to do that
again? I absolutely didn't need to do
that,
right? No, I do need it
Trace
trace. Is that
it? Come on. It's const all the way
down.
compiles.
No attribute compute vx. Yeah.
right?
Okay. One, two, three, four. Four time
serves. Three, four, four
times
gamma v trace
clip. So float
float float in two
ins. Uh should not be two
ins trays. You do not need to
pass num steps for horizon
here. These are
computed
steps. That's what you get for
uh
Okay. What did I pass
wrong? 1D important
trade. Yep.
Yep, that's it.
dummy. And this is a mismatch as
well. Yeah.
shape. Do some shape
fixing. I just want to get this to
Compute V trace was not
declared but yeah I should declare it.
All
right. Done.
Importance.
Uh,
gamma
eclipse race
sets done importance
We've got
um I'm assuming I'm not timing this
thing correctly.
That's really freaking slow for some
reason,
The CUDA one is somehow out of memory.
Cuda one somehow legal access.
Really? It's the same bloody code. So,
how do you figure
somehow and if I don't do this I
still error
train against who knows what we're
training
against. So it is this
thing values rewards
done
Yeah, I don't see anything that would be
wrong
Um, retrace
kernel. Oh, well, this is really stupid,
right? Or no, this is fine actually.
J
kernel times
horizon values
steps. Why is not longer than 256,
right?
I mean, we should probably just look at
this very
carefully. Gamma clip. Right. So, we're
passing these all in the correct order,
I'd assume, right?
horizon. So then horizon goes to beach
trace
kernel and it goes to beach row
gamma beach
row horizon.
Oh, what the heck is
this? How' that
happen? Hey, I don't know how that
No, still found legal
memory.
not recompiling it or
something. Should be
sure. That's
bizarre. It runs on the CPU. It doesn't
run on the GPU.
Why do I think it's going to end up
being something stupid that's like not
even
here? Because I like I don't see
anything here,
right? You have this buffer. This buffer
is always big
enough. Starts out at one. You go from
zero up to
horizon which definitely fits in
there. Importance is also the same size.
This the search
checked,
t and rewards at
t values t
next
t horizon minus two to
zero still fine.
Race of T. Yeah, I don't see anything
wrong with this
thing gives you numbum steps by horizon.
You've assert
checked all of
these,
thing. Yeah, it's just going to give me
illegal memory address.
There's nothing useful in
here. It's all asynchronous. So, you're
just screwed.
Let's just make sure there's not
something like
See, I don't understand how it actually
doesn't
happen. Like, we don't actually even hit
it here,
right? We hit it in one of the freaking
profilers. You would think we should hit
it here,
right? Like, how am I not hitting it
there?
something? Like where are we heading
this?
advantages. So, this doesn't get called
at all.
Uh, I get I guess it could be this
sample up here, but that would
make that wouldn't make any sense at all
to
me. It's still just in a rapper
somewhere.
this? No.
So literally somehow because this is not
even
doing anything
right. I mean I could just
like for the hell of it
Dun is float,
right? I'm sure the Dun is float. I will
double
check. We literally pass it. Yeah.
experience.
Dun just make sure
right? Could be. That could technically
be
something. Hang
on. But I I don't see how it would be.
That doesn't make any sense.
array? Oh, you idiot. Okay, I know it.
I know
it. Damn
it. All right, that's me being dumb. I
should have added a check for that.
this I forgot that uh because I'm
applying this to sample
two mini batches
essentially. You can't have as many
threads. So, it was trying to split it.
Uh, it didn't have enough data for a
full
block. Yep, there we
go. So
stupid. All right. Now, we still have
the problem of it not
training, but uh at least now we can
debug working
code. I'm way happier debugging working
code. We can see the grad variance has
just exploded
catastrophically. That was
obnoxious. That was a silly mistake as
well.
You would think you would get some kind
of error for that, but nope, you
don't. You just don't. You get out of
memory, like memory access, whatever.
So, the uh the value loss seems pretty
damn easy,
right? Like this seems
pretty
Potentially this has important sampling
on it. I missed this. What's this
row? Important sample,
right? So that row is just
ratio. What's the objective?
Why don't they write the
uh the objective here?
Just want the freaking beach race
loss. Where is it?
here still in
progress. Literally top is some random
repo.
The hell is this
sum? Where did it get this f this
formula
from? Yeah, that literally makes no
sense.
Okay.
Um, logic's actions
Wait,
what? Cross
entropy times advantages.
I like how it's trying to tell me that
the original in the original
implementation it's this way. When I
pasted the original
Um, assuming that's not like some other
baseline, right? Doesn't look like it
would be.
According to the paper, that's what it
is.
I think we need to
uh to go look at what their V trace
outputs.
Yeah, we need to go look at what their V
trace
outputs. This is not
do cross
entropy
advantages. And then this
Okay. Oh, this is some like crazy scam
thing.
Brad can create only implicitly from
blah blah
blah. All right.
really. Okay, you know what? We're going
to just
Okay. Well, this clearly still doesn't
work.
Hang
on. They have like two different things
that this function is returning.
We'll know when we get it because they
should at the very least be competitive
with uh what we have
before, what we had
before. And it should basically not work
if it's
wrong. It's so weird how they like
export
concat. Yeah. So they basically they do
one extra bootstrap value at the
end which is such a weird way of doing
it but
whatever but then they apply hang on
it's
clipped PG
rows so I think you need to return two
things from this function don't
you? Then you just need to return two
things.
clipped PG
rows
equals if clip threshold
Okay, so here are your rows,
right? This is something that we
compute. Yep, this is something that we
compute.
times. Well, this is just the
uh this is literally
just the ratio, isn't it?
I think the easiest thing is just going
to be to put this entire thing into the
kernel.
Right? The thing is you do you miss one
at the end with the way that this is
written. You literally do miss one at
the end.
See this clipped PG row is just
literally just a
clipped clipped row.
clipping. They do the clipping
differently though, don't they?
Why is their clipping like zero to one
or whatever?
You can't freaking use like I don't even
know why I open these models when
they're wrong in the first
sentence. Like literally just close
Twitter. Oh, the models are coming for
everything. The models
This ratio is still what we want though,
isn't
Okay. So that should give you clipped
row.
I think that's the
same. And
discount. Discount
times that returns
Next
minus
So, so I have this
term, but then they take this against
the soft max.
Maybe I should just do that.
Q with Z
indices which logit with indicates
I'm going to have to find like a good
reference
logits. Yeah, there's like no way to
freaking do
it. We do like pockets.
I'm just trying to get something to like
match the reference. I think I'm going
to just have to find a reference
implementation cuz the original sucks.
It's like stupid dated TensorFlow code.
This is not going to magically start
working
right for a second there
maybe, but
no. Okay. Is there an
impala Impala pietor
torch mono beast? Uh they actually have
this thing that they use for net hack,
right?
Is the whole trainer in C++ for this
crazy
this. Okay. So this is they have V trace
returns and then they call
V trace. So vtrace from
logits. Then they do
Okay. And
then their V trace here.
Python? No. No, it's not. It's okay.
It's like weird torch code.
here. Okay. Hopefully we can figure it
out from
this. What do they do it from? They do
it from logits or whatever.
from
logits. It's probably
easier. And yeah, there's also outputs
two
things. Okay.
from logits just calls from importance
pool. So this
does log props and then
subtracts. So this gives you log
rows which literally right here. So this
is log
rows. So you give this log rows and then
it does X. Yeah. So this ratio is
literally just rows,
actually.
Okay. Clip the
rows. Append bootstrapped value.
kind of wonky that they do that. I guess
they were matching the reference
implementation, but like
fine,
deltas, flipped
rows, rewards plus
discounts. Okay.
B S minus
V and they add
values. They do they add the values here
to get
values flipped PG rows. I thought we
already did
threshold. And
then here are your
advantages, which is flipped PG rows
times rewards.
Okay, I think we should be able to use
this as a reference. This is like at
least way easier to follow.
Okay, so this is row
subt P0
uh
times
rewards discount
times BST
next
minus hang on that's the
Right clipped rows. Okay. So we get this
delta and then the
accum
deltas of
t plus
discount times
deltas a
[ __ ] Is that
it? I might have this wrong. I'm one
complicated. Don't need too much space
with this. We just need this little
So they
do this product times this delta,
right? What's
actum? So yeah, this is my
be I might have to move this delta right
this product. This is C
Yes. So this is the backwards iteration
that I'm doing
So deltas of
t which is right here. I just computed
delta.
My delta is the same as
theirs. We might have screwed up the
last value. But so far this other than
that this is
fine. Add V to get V
S. Add V to get V S. What? Add V of X to
get VS.
loss. Yeah. So this
is value loss.
Let's first modify this thing to do
um to have two
inputs. So this should be
VS and advantage.
bandages. So this is going to
be BS
float
bandages. Okay.
And this
[Music]
is
important. Uh does C++ do multiple
returns?
um we'll move
this to this B trades
check. Oh, you can't return it from
PyTorch then either, can
I mean, we were probably going to just
eventually pass it in anyways,
right?
[Music]
Okay, so we get BS
advantages and then we pass
in yes advantages to the
So we get this
accum. So we just
do s of
t
plus values of
t and then the PG
advantages
times rewards
t plus
gamma. This is not values.
This is B S + one minus
Isn't that just you put this
here,
there. Okay, let's get this to compile
and then we'll with the uh the
formula,
right? We're getting close though. We're
definitely getting close to
this. I hope it
works. I mean, like, I hope the correct
implementation's actually good.
Okay,
cool. Uh, these chaos are crap. It's
funny this is not immediately
exploded. So, we should actually just be
pretty chill right now,
right? This should literally just be um
maybe new value minus returns.
Yeah, that's it.
Do we have to do this like weird shift
thing
anymore? I don't think we do, right?
Can't we literally just do
GT
shape. What's
The first few logics being zero is weird
as
hell. We should probably investigate
that.
it. They had this loss
here. So they did as
run. Okay, now I have it implemented the
way that they have it
implemented, right?
ingredients and then they sum and
there's no negative on this thing,
right? Yeah. Okay. So, this is good.
low because there's nothing happening.
It's predicting zeros and the kale is
blown
up. Presumably something is wrong
there. So, let's see. Uh let's go back
to this then.
returns. Let's go through this thing
with
a fine tooth comb. Right.
So these C's
are clamped to rows,
right? They also did this like shifted
array thing. No big
deal. And their
deltas flipped rows.
Yeah. So this we have this as well,
right? And then this
read this is not how I read this CS of
T, right?
correct? That would be a major
discrepancy. Let me
see.
So they just get rows from this log
ratio
here. They clamp them
CS make no changes and then yeah here
they have this.
But in the
impala? So in the paper they
have it.
um Hold on. There's a recursive formula
for
recursively. Okay. So this is the
formula they're using, right?
is okay. Okay, so this is the formula
that they're
using and let me let me compare theirs
to
this. So they do
B XS
act is VSP +
1 minus V of
T. Oh, because they have this minus
values here,
right? Okay, hang on. Let me let me see
if I can align it with this then. I
think they're doing like several things.
Screwy. So, we're not going to need this
at all.
Um, we are going to need clip
CT
float CT.
clamp
rows and flip rows. Yeah, these can
technically have different flip
thresholds, right? They don't, but they
can. So then what we do is we get our
delta.
we get our deltas is going to
rows. Hang on. I want to make sure we
get the mathematically
correct definition
Yeah, it is the clipped thing. Okay,
that's fine.
So
row delta is equal to
rotate
rewards
plus
gamma times
values times next terminal.
minus values.
advantages is equal
to
do this accum first is deltas plus
gamma.
C
T next
terminal. So gamma *
C*
BS is you add values to
this
right to accumul
discount. This is BT + 1.
minus values of t. I think this is
correct. And we'll
say think this is
correct. We're going to be able to
remove this whole product thing as
well. So this ends up actually being
that bad codewise,
it. The value loss is low. It's the KL
that's screwing.
So presumably I'm still optimizing that
thing wrong.
again. You put your importance ratio
which is this X, right?
in? You pass in ratio,
right?
So you get your rows which are just
flipped to
max. And this is exactly how I was doing
the
clipping. Wait,
fax. You have this backwards, don't
you? This is F
min. You don't need to clip. Yep. You're
clipping the wrong here.
This is F
wrong. Every time, every bug is a little
closer to having this thing
working. All
right, so
min.
Yeah, that
one. Now we try again.
Every time it's like, oh, it's
optimizing.
Nope. You can see from the kales. The
kales are all all
screwy. Keep looking at this line by
line.
Delta
row
reward
discount next
value terminal minus values of
T and then a
Q deltas of T delta
It's
discount
CST
this. This gives you Vs minus
V. You add
value, right? You add the values
And
then the advantage here is the main
thing. Row times rewards of
t gamma discount non-term minus
values. And this B S T + one.
So they just took
this the last term here is the value
minus. So the last one of
these is going to
of
t. You're missing a
term. This accum should probably start
off
loss. This has got to be so close though
at this point, right?
here make sure we do this correct. So we
absolutely know this file is not the
issue.
this. What's wrong with logic being like
why are logic
zeros? That's super screwy, isn't
up. We're missing like a ton of
observations in here, right?
It's
bizarre. I will double check in a second
that this still trains with
advantages samples.
You get your
batch.
Okay. Actions.
Okay, so you have your
advantage mean
of the way that they did. This
was Oh, did you miss a log
softmax? I think you missed a log soft
max. Hang on.
broken. Logic should be just what comes
out of the policy, right?
Make sure there's not like a separate
param or some weird
thing. You can see the kale still
screwed up.
detach. I don't It's weird that they sum
that,
but it's definitely supposed to be a
meme.
Well, at least now we know that we have
this correct,
right? This It's got to be
solid. The baseline is going to just be
loss. Ah, so this is returns minus your
value returns equals DS, right?
value
loss. So, this is good right
here. We're happy with
Now be very very carefully go through
this one more time.
record
min. It gives you a
delta
is flipped
row reward at time t.
Gamma value at
time t next t +
I'm
going deltas of t.
Wait. Yeah, this is fine. So this is
delta
gamma
They have to reverse their thing because
they did it
weirdly.
VS cumulate plus
values. And then what we did
here is make
sure broadcasted bootstrap values
Is this a different threshold? PG row
threshold. We should probably check this
right now. These are both set to one
reward
plus
values. The last value of this is going
to be the last
value we have here.
We do all this and our policy gradient
still explodes.
It's a reasonable PG loss right there.
Right.
I'm not seeing the explosion happen
instantly.
actually like pretty reasonable for
quite a while. It does eventually blow
up a fair
bit. What about the uh was old
KL. So, so it's like 90 whatever%
clipping. Is it immediately 90%
clipping? Yes, it's immediately 90%
clipping. 60 or whatever.
So what is this
There's no clip that goes on this floss.
Stop it.
Try to run PO real quick. See if I broke
anything. I did.
PO. We see small positive policy
loss, very small chaos.
Hello YouTube folks. We are hopefully
pretty close to having V trace
implemented into Puffer.
This would hopefully stabilize the
advantage filtering stuff we've been
doing and also maybe maybe just allow us
to throw a little bit of off policy
data into the uh the
buffer once it
works. Okay, so these are tiny tiny tiny
numbers,
right? Okay, so how is it that
immediately these numbers
are messed up?
I do wonder if there's something to
this.
Yeah, they shouldn't be diverged that
much immediately.
What happens if we
um
this? Okay.
So that actually does change stuff, but
you still learn with
PO,
right? So you start off with these
approx like 0.5 and
2. You end up with a pretty damn high
clip
fract. But you still
learn and uh the tails do not blow up.
Policy loss does not blow up. Value loss
does not blow up. And it still works.
But there's quite a bit of
clipping. This thing not being clipped
is the problem.
see you whatever I do it's still it just
the KLs blow up instantly
um we can print the values as well,
right?
These are not
exploding. Yeah. So, these are not
exploding as far as I can
This wait value equal batch valvalues
button.
Uh that's going to
uncip the value
loss, but the V loss is not blowing up
anyways. And that should be the more
stable of the losses.
next? Maybe we go
check. Let's go back to their code for a
second. Check a couple things.
max. It's clamped to a
max.
So we
do V trace from
policy. Why do we have two different
outputs
here? Oh, this is just for the ratio.
That's fine.
The
rewards the baseline
here
value and then they compute policy
gradient
Presumably they have a negative sign as
well. They're on entropy.
targets. Multiply
these. It's already detached.
from logits
here action log
props log
props
difference you get log
rows and you're going immediately exit
I think what we can even do to check
this
because this is identical.
see. Let's see if these advantages look
good.
then why does this get bigger and
bigger? Ah, because you get another one
right here. Right.
That looks like
pretty
sane reasonable stuff to me.
right. Yeah, actually tomorrow it's
good.
So, isn't there there's supposed to be a
value bootstrap, isn't
there?
like that doesn't look quite right to
me, right?
So this gets
no reward, but it does have the value on
it,
right? Do you think you need the
advantage normalization?
fair. We'll try that in a second. Let me
just check one
thing. So if you get no reward, what's
the formula supposed to
do? The way they have
it. Where's
B. All right. So, the way that they have
this
This is going to be
one. This is
So it's this minus
values. So V ST +
one. So this should literally end up
being
like Yeah, it's just going to be like
this number minus this number.
like that, right?
Yeah. So, a very small number is
appropriate because it just it ends up
being the value difference between two
states. Let me try advantage
man. See, now the KL's fine, but the
value loss is
screwed. Well, that is probably the
thing that I broke from before, right?
So now the value loss is still exploding
just less
quickly. Make sure that um we still can
train PO on this.
works. Does it work without value
function clipping?
right? Maybe even
better. Okay, so that might even be
better.
And it's clip to the clip
coefficient, which is kind of funny.
Yeah. So,
um, is the value loss just done now? Is
that what's happening?
returns versus new value.
So we
have new
returns and set that right
there to
This thing has just got to be blowing up
completely,
I mean, this is the one that was that
should be easy to get
This thing should end up being pretty
small.
values.
This Yeah, we can do that. Why not?
explodes. This thing just gets bigger
and bigger.
There's not even a sign difference.
Wait, the fact that there's not a sign
difference. Batch
values, that means that
like the values and the returns actually
kind of
match. The returns just make no bloody
sense, right?
Because all you're supposed to do is
just
like
Maybe I need to do
this. Maybe this feels here.
up.
Okay. Why Why is it like this?
and check against the math. I
guess
lambda. Hey captain, been building a
planter. I've been implementing V trace
all day.
I like to be building a planner. That
sounds
C. Does this need a
minus?
No. Right.
Carpenter was showing me a few other
guys some tricks. TLDDR V trace uh
replacement for generalized advantage
estimation that should be better at off
policy correction. So it should allow us
to get more out of the new experience
buffer.
similar to to uh generalized advantage
estimation. It ditches the lambda term
and instead it threads a
um it threads the important sampling
term that's used for the advantage
function uh or used to scale was it to
clip the policy gradient. Yeah. Instead,
it threads that through the advantage
computation.
not max brad norm. It's
um it's a logic ratio of the new policy
to the old policy before you started
optimizing at this
epoch. So that then means that the
clipping term also gets applied to the
the clipping term gets like deeply
applied to the value function as well
but not just like as a post hawk thing.
What are you doing?
I'm currently attempting to implement a
CUDA kernel for this vtrace off policy
correction advantage estimate from
impala into puffer so that we can uh
leverage some like slightly off policy
data with our
implementation abandoning P30 for now or
do you think the new will experience
buffer? Uh, so VRC is still very similar
to generalized advantage estimation and
like pretty much anything that I was
going to do with
P30 on top of J I could do it with V
trace as well.
So, Vray still has the annoying lambda
uh the annoying gamma parameter, though
arguably it should be slightly easier to
deal with because it no longer has the
lambda
parameter. So actually I think that
probably once I get this thing
implemented fully, this will probably be
a little easier to work with for like P3
style stuff versus
J. How much testing of the experience
buffer? Not a ton, but I mean we have
results on we've got results on like
neural MMO stuff. Actual cube. That's
soda right there. So there you go.
That's soda with advantage filtering. Um
So, yeah, it's pretty good. The curves
aren't quite as clean, though, so we're
we're gonna have to clean some stuff up
there. But, uh, yeah, it's been pretty
decent overall.
doesn't take much of an SPS. It
shouldn't be shouldn't change the SPS at
all. There's like one slight thing that
we might have to consider when we do
filtering with this, but it should be
fine.
It only screws over the SPS if you have
like a two million step per second
training run and then you don't
implement a CUDA kernel for this. And lo
and behold to the colonel.
I
mean, we kind of should just go off of
this reference, right? Where is
it? I'm trying to think what the odds
are that I missed. I just missed
something in here even though I've
looked at it 10 times.
Oh, that blows up instantly.
Okay.
up. Where did that freaking
implementation just go?
one. Maybe this is an issue. Hang
on. So, we
do t + one
So this gets all the
deltas.
Okay.
And this accumulator
silly. Okay. So that's interesting,
right? The value loss
like Yeah, the losses are like kind of
the same until uh I guess the policy
where the KL tends to blow up. That's
better
though. Okay, then maybe this thing's
just really sensitive. Maybe I have some
like really minor minor details screwed
up.
So the delta, you're missing the last
delta, right?
missing the last delta.
next. Maybe I have this wrong still.
Hang
on. Wait, I do have this wrong, right?
I do have this wrong. Hang on. I think I
see it. B ST +
Yeah. All right. I got to get the
restroom and then I think I can fix
this. I think I see it. Right back.
So here's the thing,
right? This
is V S T +
one. This should not be a cube. This
should be V
S T + 1.
mean, which is going to start out at
zero.
Possibly we're going to have to add um
the
terminal bootstrap value. We'll
see. This thing still immediately blows
up.
How many bugs do I have to fix before
this thing
behaves? Look at this
chaos. Okay.
probably
not. I don't think this fixes it though,
right? I don't I don't think that
fixes. I'll run it, but I think we keep
looking.
discounts t
next values of
t. Yeah, this stupid thing is just going
to
keep
breaking. Okay, let's think about
terminal or bootstrap final
value.
So, yeah. So, it's it's just the last
value, right?
B ST +
algorithm. Okay, I must have missed
something else, right? Like
Okay. So,
delta is going to
grab t next, right?
[ __ ] So this whole thing should be
fine. Oh wait, the only thing is that
this the last BS is going to be
wrong. Hang on. The last BS is going to
be wrong.
What's the last PS supposed to
be? And it's supposed to be bootstrap
value.
right? Yeah, I just did that and that
didn't make it. Like that didn't fix it
magically.
This guy has a pretty nice paper. It's
uh was it beyond the rainbow? It's uh
basically rainbow, which is all the
kitchen sink of tricks that they threw
on DQM. Well, this guy found another
kitchen sink worth of tricks to throw on
it, and it did a lot better.
This is discord.gg/puffer GG/huffer if
anyone is interested want to get
involved.
We don't get a break on this
thing. This still needs to get done
today. I mean, they just used the
bootstrap value at the very end,
values? No, they do use it there as
well, don't
they? They use the bootstrap value at
the end here as well.
Finally helps increasing action
gaps and therefore reducing policy
turning off
policiness. This policy isn't based on
the value function directly at
least increasing action gaps.
trolled? I'm not actually getting
trolled.
Love to see people using the algorithm
as fast as possible.
This would be a very cool guy to get
involved with. Buffer
still have to finish this uh beach race.
We don't get a pass on
this. I do not know what's wrong with it
though. Hang on. We are messing with
this uses.
I doubt you can get that speed, but
technically technically this BT plus one
could be
off. Soda all policy uses fairly long
traces uses 160.
Interesting steps. Extremely slow.
No, I got to read that paper for sure. I
think we start with this thing
though. What's this paper
from? Is this recentish or
Each forward pass slows down a lot.
do so many poor passes kills.
two weeks for an Atari game. It's crazy.
It's not like one policy and everything,
right? Yeah, it's still one each, I
think.
I I actually think that I do have this
right now, don't
I? I
miss I missed the last delta, I believe.
delta. What does that do? Missing the
last
delta. Do I have like some weird off by
one on the
advantages? Could be.
I don't think so though.
Oh jeez. They actually roll it out like
160 time steps and then they throw away
159 of
them. Crazy.
I didn't try without normalizing
advantages until I since I did this,
right? I didn't try without normalizing
advantages. Maybe that maybe you can't
normalize advantages in this.
Did I really just casually do that? Hang
on. Is this the
baseline? No, this is not the
baseline. We just got V trace
See if we uh we can
do we can get rid of this
off policy or bottlenecks by gradient
steps more than anything
start benchmarking a little
bit. That's
awesome. All of a sudden, it
works. Also, yeah, that's definitely
Soda.
Okay, it's not quite on par yet, right?
But this is also no advantage filtering
like brand new thing that we just
implemented.
filter? Well, let's make a commit right
now.
because
right, we're actually going to do some B
trade stuff real quick. So, this guy is
cool to chat with. Um, I actually I
really wanted to have somebody with off
policy experience for a while, like
actually like good off policy
experience.
uh doing some stuff around in puffer and
yeah from that manuscript this guy would
be perfect for
that. You can check out his paper. It's
on open review beyond the rainbow. It's
uh pretty nice additions to rainbow DQN
and pretty well done science too.
and two weeks to 12 hours.
Apex stuff for
BTR. Haven't seen Apex in a long
time. God damn
Okay. So, the plan with this stuff right
here would
compute how do we compute V
trace? I guess all we have to do is add
We massively lower the replay ratio.
Interesting.
I think all you have to do for
experience, right, is you just have to
initialize.
right?
Because well, it is going to be one to
start with,
right? Wait, it's literally always going
to be one.
to start with.
No, I guess yeah, initially it should
just
be we can just do like
would be like experience importance
here. Maybe
advantage. A lot of my work focus on
fairly slow sim.
5:14 right now. I'm going to try and
implement this oneation. I'm going to
order dinner. I'll dev for like half
hour or whatever. Get dinner and then
I'll come back for another couple hours.
I think that's the plan.
um yeah, you don't actually know what
this ratio is.
until you do the forward
pass,
right? Oh, that's not an issue though,
is
it? No, that's not an
issue. Cuz then all you just do is you
just do
experience
or ex ratio.
Right. Perfect. So we finish that
conversation. We
fine. And then Yeah, this should be
fine. Let's We'll
The amount of supposedly Asian food in
uh Florida is very concerning.
Okay, I am actually going to order food
while I fix this because otherwise I'm
going to
like
Just real
quick, it'll be quicker if I do this on
here, assuming that uh I still have my
credentials in. And then we'll come back
and we'll let me order dinner and then
we'll actually we'll get some cool uh
experiments going and I'll actually talk
through stuff. I was a little distracted
with that conversation, but
um yeah, we will actually get some cool
experiments
in. Got to love how Florida the average
like distance to get food is like 10
miles.
What in the
heck? It's actually not bad. That's not
a bad
idea. Okay, local pups got me.
stuff and uh we will run these
experiments.
One
second. Hey bet.
research. So, Here's the thing with B
trace, right? Um, it requires an
importance
ratio. The importance ratio, we're not
going to deal
with historical buffers for now,
but it should always start off as an
important ratio
one because it's the ratio of new policy
logics to old policy logics. And at the
start of any, new policy equals old
policy.
Um, so we should be able to do something
like
that. Oh yeah, and now we just have to
debug some shape stuff and we should
actually be able to compare this to what
I was doing earlier.
This is the
issue. I can I Yeah, I just know that's
the issue here. Let me just fix that.
This needs to
uh we can call this
advantages. No reason not
to experience
Where is the It's beyond the rainbow.
It's this.
Yeah. Yeah, it's this thing. There's uh
I guess it is on archive then. There's
an archive. I was looking at the open
review version. From the format, it
looks about the same.
discord. That's the goal eventually is
just to have all the all the cool RL
people on the
Discord. Whenever I have a question
about anything, it's just like ah
they're all right here.
uh, what we're [ __ ] with at the
moment is not quite off policy. It is an
off policy correction technique applied
to on policy.
Uh, yeah, that didn't freaking work, now
did
it?
Batch. Is it like
batchadvantages? PO arguably
has not except for the dev branch. It
doesn't.
I mean the buffer branch, not even the
dev branch, the more more recent
branch. Okay, so we do actually have
advantages in the buffer.
Perfect. So now this is actually got to
be experience or is it
back advantages?
sampling. It crashes.
Really?
bug. Do I have a
bug? Hang
on. Am I not being smart about this?
So every mini batch we recomputee B
Actually, this shouldn't matter though,
right?
Wait. No, this is
correct. Is equal to ratio. Yeah. Yeah,
this is
correct. It should be
logit actions.
uh still on random sampling is the
thing. So that advantage didn't factor
in.
It's really weird that that is uh
unstable. Let's just make sure we didn't
get
unlucky. I don't think
No, we didn't get
unlucky. The kale blows up.
back? Hang on. Do I roll this back or do
I just
compare? It's a good thing. And this is
why I made a commit.
Uh 15 20 minutes before
food. Getting very
hungry.
Uh okay.
So from
file
puffer clean
puff good time to remind folks you want
to help me out for free just started the
give almost at 2k stars and it really
helps.
Not that many RL post with 2K
stars, especially not in like one year
of fulltime
dev. Okay. So in this one here, I gave
it
once
and I sampled
But this shouldn't matter because it's
random sampling
anyways, right? And then in
trace. Yeah. Start of the buffer. Uh you
and then here we get VS vantage.
values. What is the difference between
computing it here and
then elsewhere?
Oh, hang
on. Yeah. No, you can't do
this. The uh the importance ratio gets
stale this way,
right? Yeah. The importance ratio gets
stale. Okay. So, I have to go back.
We go back
this. We go back to this and make sure
this still runs. And then what we can do
Let me see how prioritized experience
replays update formula works.
error and then they update the
priorities with a new TD error after a
learning step.
thing your value this is going to get
slightly stale
for Yeah, it's better to make that.
Okay, that's fine. Yeah, I see it. I
think I see it now, folks. I see it. So,
we have advantages here.
Okay. So, we do importance. It's going
to start uniform.
Um, I think that'll do it. That's not a
Neptune
mismatching. Oh yeah, this importance
doesn't need to be
Yeah, this importance needs to be uh
data.experience
Oh, I think that it literally it does.
Okay. Port one to
like. Okay.
So, this should still
work like
Oh, it eats the batch advantages,
doesn't it?
this. Okay, this runs
right explode instantly. No. Okay, we
track
this and we see if we have broken
anything or not. And if we haven't, the
key thing is now we should actually be
able to add in
uh we should actually be able to add in
the advantage
filtering. Here's our
run. This should be like about what this
yellow curve is.
1 minute 80 milstep training rooms are
very
nice. Yeah. Okay. This looks like this
is about the yellow, right? It's already
up to seven. Yeah. So, this is about on
par with the uh the yellow curve.
do, delete this line. Rerun it. We
should have important sampling.
worse. Okay,
good. Yeah, this is uh this is what we
want. This is what we wanted to see.
I think it is better. We got to wait for
the curve. But I think
so. Okay. Yeah, that is better. Perfect.
So um then the question is going to be
experience and then it's the importance
gets updated to this. And the only other
thing we have to do is we have to
remember to zero it.
way rerun so that we make sure we didn't
break anything and then we will run with
bros. Food is here in like a few
minutes. more
experiments and then that'll set a
decent tempo. I don't expect the off
policy to work immediately by the way. I
don't expect it to work
immediately. I just wanted to have V
trace and now we have V
trace which technically kills a
hyperparameter.
If it matches in perf, it's better just
because it kills hyper
parameter. Okay, that looks good. Now we
set replay factor equal
one. Set like 0.5.
Maybe 0.5 should be plenty.
be replay factor 0.5 means it's allowed
to keep up to half a batch of data
across EOPS. So it is actually allowed
to use fully stale data.
Yeah, I think it's going to be
um the same stale result here.
How long is it keeping it? As long as it
likes. It's based on um well, it should
be based on a priority metric, but we
got to improve on that. Okay. So, this
does not uh vrace did not magically let
us use all policy data yet. We will
continue to work on that. We will get a
actual proper prioritized replay buffer
and we will do some other stuff for that
though. Change the 05. Well, that was
the point of the test to see whether you
could use
Yeah, that's
fine. All right, I will be back after
dinner. Um, probably should be back
dinner for at least like an hour or so.
for folks
watching puffer.ai for all my stuff.
Reinforcement learning dev live almost
every day. Uh start the GitHub to help
us out. It really helps. We've got lots
of fun demos on here, lots of different
games, all with neural net that run in
your
browser. If you want to get involved
with dev, join the discord. Some of our
best contributors came in with zero RL
experience.
And you can follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning
content. It's all RL all the time.
[Music]